big news shaking up the resort industry  today yeah wynn resorts ceo matt maddox  is ending his tenure as head of the  company maddox has been win resort ceo  and a member of the board of directors  since february 2018 he's been with wynn  resorts for nearly two decades maddox  says he carried on steve wynn's vision  of excellence and that his exit was  actually delayed so that he could help  guide the company through the covid  pandemic  it's been 20 years exactly what i wanted  to achieve we've done and i feel like  the management team that's in place the  people that are in place and where this  company is that it's the right time for  me to go do something else which i'm  quite excited about  craig billings will take over february  1st billings is a ceo of wynn  interactive and has served as president  and cfo of wynn resorts